[Music]
[Applause]
the winners of mlg anaheim
the first time i heard about crimson he
had just made the transition from a halo
professional into call of duty and he
was killing it and killing it and there
was a lot of coverage on there
he's gonna kill him
let him know that is a huge performance
from six
the curse has been broken the dynasty
has been cemented
[Applause]
[Music]
i wanted revenge i still want revenge i
literally wake up
walk outside my bedroom see them and i'm
instantly motivated
any thought of like doing anything else
other than playing it goes
out the window right when i see that
right when i see that stupid
poster that could be it maven
shotzy and hoop go huge the contest is
there for a second but it's
it's not dallas empire with their second
home series win they go through chicago
they go through atlanta and now in my
eyes
submit themselves as the top team in the
game
started his competitive call of duty
journey in 2012
when his original game of choice halo
was bumped off the mlg circuit by black
ops 2.
after making the switch crimson joined
complexity and once they made a few
midseason roster shuffles the team
really started picking up steam crim6
and x half the front unlocked
tp watching the point one go away
that is that complexity takes out impact
and they are crowned the winners of mlg
anaheim
but it wasn't just a player's skill that
made complexity so good
it was the fact that the whole team was
focused on one
goal victory i probably learned
that from complexity because on
complexity
it was like the it was like there was
four of me
on the same team crimsix took tournament
after
tournament and complexity became a force
to be reckoned with hasn't got much
choice is the kill gonna come down
turns on him now he's gonna be spacing
at one versus one against crim can he
find the kill
he's not behind him
oh my grip with the dukes the last one
alive
crims six this is game number two for
optic if they can finish the round krim
gets one though staying alive 49 seconds
left on the clock so patient is crimson
but he is to be called out catching oh
in transition one more player can crim
get the one on three
oh he's fighting him
six with the one on three complexity's
momentum continued into call of duty
ghosts and
after adding the 2013 world champion
karma to the team
they won a world championship of their
own and krimsix kept pushing
climbing higher and higher on the
competitive ladder and krim has no idea
where this player is and he's got one
pushing here he is able to take him out
will we make it too into you
krim is just in beast mode today it's
sunday we're gonna call
there's a
sweet baby quad jesus oh my goodness
what a play out of crimson he gets what
was that
i'll make it seven heaven now crimson
you
are the terminator in the middle of an
incredible series of wins complexity
announced that they were selling their
roster to eg for a pretty hefty sum
and even under a new org krimsix
continued to do what he did
best most kills we've ever seen in sd is
19
karma cleans up center so any two
players left he needs to come both
there's one
that's 19 50 second place in here no he
gets
hit markers no oh saints picks up two
it's a one-on-one a one-on-one for the
20th kill
now chris turn around
he doesn't want to get the twentieth
thanks versus scrim
can't say he's gonna kill grab job
let him know that is a huge performance
from krimsix
but even though krimsix was playing out
of his mind eg wasn't
looking so hot and with 20 seconds left
optic gaming
have done what was the impossible they
have taken
down eg eg will not be in a grand final
for the first time in a very very long
time and look how much that means to the
boys in the booth pocket
coming back from the x games we didn't
win we didn't even get
second we got [ __ ] third at g3
eg didn't make top four and that meant
they didn't make any money
the first time that it ever happened to
krimsix in his entire career
base is moving on the world champions
eliminated outside of the money
for the first time here in london just
like that
one of the most legendary rosters in cod
history fell into ruin
and crimstic's legacy looked shot like
when i
sit down every single day and practice
and prepare i'd rather be reminded of
like
like this is what happens if you don't
work hard this is what happens if you
you know don't prepare advanced warfare
marked a new beginning for krimsix
he and some of his old eg teammates were
released from their contracts
and it didn't take him a long to find a
new home in coding
with two now looking for a third gift
and as well
for all three wow is that possible
that is game five crim at its finest
right there krimsix joined
optic the team that he'd spend the next
five years of his career with
the team that would cement his legacy in
the game
and the team that may have ruined his
reputation forever
i've always approached situations with
one idea in mind
that i will do anything i need to do to
win
crimsix has always been passionate about
the game he plays
and that's come through in more ways
than one interacting with teammates and
fans helped crimstix find his voice
i'm not shy anymore like i used to be i
used to be really quiet really shy
and you know video games has actually
helped me a lot with that but in the
heat of the moment
that voice could get a little intense
we're not gonna not say anything to like
if someone [ __ ] up we're gonna be like
listen you [ __ ] up and they're not
gonna take it personally because
we all know that you know like we're
friends and stuff but
we're teammates first call of duty has a
long-standing tradition
of using rivalries to get the fans
excited about the games
people love a good fight but this
was different no i'm saying [ __ ] play
style bro
yeah are you an ar are you a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
like [ __ ] dude son if you would have
died right there and that guy would have
been killing you while i ran by i would
have killed the hill guy i
would have blocked spawns don't let this
guy finesse you for 20 seconds
dude nah you're just looking for [ __ ] to
[ __ ] about this point crimson's
communication with his teammates got a
little
too heated for the fans liking it's like
people get mad when you don't talk to
teammates like the other human beings
pretty much but at the end of the day
like you look at all
traditional sports and all this and that
and you don't see
coaches walking up to someone taking
five minutes to explain something that
could be explained in five seconds
you're not [ __ ] listening i just got
two sets of streaks in one life
shut up you are [ __ ] so immature top
right window
so from the outside looking in crimson
looked pretty toxic
but he was getting results caesar played
to the right
grim six makes it a one versus one let's
be a three b one we have seen
him do things like this before do it
he's gonna do it he gets it
chrome six the four kill streak the one
versus three well they just got actually
picked off by clay murkets another crims
six
in a one versus three but if anyone can
do it it is krembot
yeah if anybody can do this is krim
right now at nine on four i mean
just playing phenomenal just all day
long he's got a lot of time yeah he's
got a bunch of time i mean he
can just get one of these players and
dash out of there pretty quick maven he
has a decent chance of punching 1v2 he's
going to pick up one kill right there
and he's going to be able to get
he's challenging he's crazy he's going
to challenge he's crazy and he's going
to be able to kill him
he'll all get eyes on but j cap stay
and the fact that krimsix wanted to win
no matter whose feelings he hurt to get
there
made him a pretty scary opponent you
know because obviously
you're like me you have a very very
strong personality
you're not afraid to speak truths or you
know hold back because
you know someone's feelings if we're
both trying to succeed in this thing
yeah right like
you know we're here to win and you're
doing something wrong i'm going to call
you out because
you know what just in case you don't
[ __ ] know yeah right the way i see it
on a team especially in call of duty
right
if everyone is on the same page doing
the wrong play
yeah that team is better than the team
that's on not on the same page doing the
right play and though some people were
always ready to hate on krm6
it never took away from his value as a
player you know chrome 6 and his
attitude
it certainly has its downsides but he
brings a lot more to his team than he
takes away from it
he's such a like such a no-nonsense type
of person and i think that's what makes
him
one of the best shot callers that we've
seen in competitive call of duty ever
crim6 had his toxic moments but the fact
of the matter is
he was a key part of the greatest
dynasty in cod
history the curse has been broken
the dynasty has been cemented
they are the greatest monster in call of
duty history
[Applause]
[Music]
but the magic couldn't last forever
the world war ii season brought optic's
legendary roster to its knees
fresh faces came in to help the team
rebound a little bit but behind the
scenes
the green wall was crumbling optic
dropped krimsix he says he never saw it
coming
and that his new teammates pushed him
out of the team he helped build
shots were fired and a few of optic's
remaining squad
fired back me and matt were the best
statistically and damon was the
dirty worker and crim like
i mean like he did his part obviously
but like we won him
so much money in so many tournaments and
obviously again he did his part but like
we were the ones that were
really frying like frying people and
i just don't get it you know it was time
to move on and
let it be at that despite the back and
forth krimsix was more motivated than
ever i wanted revenge i still want
revenge i actually
have a damon damon holly actually made
me this
it was a poster of the optic iw team
winning
the the champs there so seth and
and matt might not see me every day but
i see them
i literally wake up walk outside my
bedroom see them and i'm
instantly motivated any thought of like
doing
anything else other than playing it goes
out the window right when i see that
right when i see that stupid
poster crimsix joined the dallas empire
and after reuniting with an old friend
from his complexity days
they became one of the top teams in the
league
with the fifth and that could be it
maven shotsy and hoop go
huge the contest is there for a second
but it's not
enough it's the dallas empire with their
second home series win and despite
getting revenge on his former teammates
krimsix isn't letting it go to his head
everyone
that's expecting me to trash talk and do
this and that
listen i'm i've never been a sore winner
i've been a sore winner one time
in my whole career i'm not gonna talk
trash it's just a
semi-final match online you know
all the people with skump and formal
shrines in their closet you guys can
hold the lane crown whatever i don't
care
you know it was gg's it was a fun match
uh but now on to the next one whatever
may have happened in the past
chrome 6 is determined to focus on the
future
one step at a time thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages